fondamentalmente non ho nessun tipo di
esperienza di non sono un esperto e
niente non ho fatto delle formazioni
particolari tutta la mia esperienza
viene da una profonda curiosità nelle
cose nel quello che vedo quello che in
conto e questo è quello che faccio
quotidianamente l'unica cosa che che
faccio quindi una cosa che ho pensato
intanto di poter fare di presentarmi di
dirvi chi sono da dove vengo e che cosa
faccio e poi magari vi interesserà
qualcosa quando mi chiedono che cosa
faccio come il lavoro ma la cosa più
facile dire sono un fotografo che è la
risposta più semplice e diretta
in realtà quello che faccio è un
miscuglio di cose e che fondamentalmente
è stato seguire le mie passioni
ho sempre seguito le mie passioni
seguito quello che avevo voglia di fare
e spessissimo sono poi diventate dei
lavori nella strada facendo
adesso è cambiato scusate 11 vede così
che ho fatto qualche anno fa è stato
creare uno spazio di coworking a roma
il 2008 è uno spazio come questo che mi
ha portato nel mondo dell'economia
collaborativa della partecipazione della
collaborazione
un'altra delle mie passioni è quella di
viaggiare e di provare le cose in prima
persona questo miscuglio di di
esperienze ha fatto sì che ho iniziato a
girare a fotografare molti eventi e
spazi in tutto il mondo dove avvenivano
cose di economia
molto spesso legate al mondo
dell'economia collaborativa attualmente
mi occupo di un progetto che si chiama
cobas e che permette a gente come me che
di lavorare ovunque nel mondo
appoggiarlo e sugli spazi di coworking
fondamentalmente quello che mi piace
fare quotidianamente e sperimentare e di
di fare esperienze e di trovare anche
altri modi di vivere la condivisione
quando la condivisione non è una
piattaforma web facebook twitter ma è un
modo di vivere in modo di vivere reale
quotidiano di vita l'ho portato qui
alcuni esempi di cose che mi hanno
colpito andando in giro per farvi capire
più o meno di che cosa si tratta
qui per esempio eravamo in senegal e
questa famiglia non è la nostra famiglia
erano semplicemente le persone che
abitano attualmente nella casa dove mia
moglie è abitato da piccola
e pochi minuti dopo abbiamo fatto questa
foto è stata un'accoglienza da parte di
persone completamente sconosciute come
se fossimo della famiglia abbiamo
mangiato insieme ci hanno addirittura
vestito da da africani fatto dei regali
che questa si è successo tutto in
mezz'ora pochissimi minuti
prestissimo qui in europa bussando a una
volta che ho conosciuto dicendogli vai
ho abitato qui quando ero piccolo ok
arrivederci se invece qui si aumenta e
adesso siamo in contatto e spesso ci
sentiamo un'altra esperienza che mi ha
colpito molto
questa scuola in cambogia non so se
questo avviene in tutte le scuole della
cambogia o per puro caso ho trovato
questa qui
questi bambini praticamente arrivano
mezz'ora prima degli altri mezz'ora
prima del dei professori arrivano a
scuola iniziano a pulire la scuola
bruciano tutte le le sporcizie che hanno
trovato si occupa della scuola senza
nessuna presenza di professori ed
insegnanti quindi sono i primi a
occuparsi della pulizia della scuola e
che tutto si fa sta bene
durante la giornata di studio poi vanno
a comprarsi da soli la la merenda e poi
aspettano che arrivano i professori
questo mi ha stupito enormemente che il
senso di responsabilità e di cura che
hanno per lo spazio è impressionante
rispetto a magari bambini di sempre qui
in europa o in america che non
l'impressione che non hanno alcun
rispetto per il luogo dove dove studiano
il capoclasse poi si occupa di di
metterli in file di fare la sua bandiera
e poi solo in questo momento arrivano
gli adulti e comincia la giornata di
studio questo è un altro caso che è
veramente particolare tra l'altro come
in modo di condivisione per tantissimi
casi è un'isola nel
nel lago titicaca l'isola ditta chi le
queste persone hanno deciso di dopo un
primo inizio di turismo normale di
rivenire o turismo sostenibile quindi
hanno rifiutato qualsiasi tipo di
turismo di massa
non ci sono hotel non ci sono strutture
turistiche l'unico modo di andare
sull'isola essere ospitati dalle
famiglie locali e tutto il beneficio
fatto da questo tipo di turismo va tutta
la comunità non ha solo alla famiglia
che vi ospita questo è un momento molto
particolare sapevo interessante
chiedergli che cosa stava avvenendo
perché si stavano scambiando delle
foglie di coca foglie di coca e sono
molto utili in in alta quota per
sopportare l'ossigenazione del sangue e
nel loro è un modo di dire sì buongiorno
un modo di salutarsi c'è uno scambio di
foglie di coca per assicurarsi che tutta
la popolazione abbia abbastanza coca per
stare bene
la prima cosa che si fa incontrandosi e
assicurarsi che tutti abbiano una
quantità sufficiente per stare bene su
quest'isola praticamente ci sono tre
leggi 1 e non mentire
2 non rubare e prendono oziare non fare
sempre qualcosa
questo fa sì che queste persone sono
regolate da queste tre norme che
derivano dal dagli inca e sull'isola c'è
una vita molto gradevole molto condivisa
il per esempio detto e mi ha stupito
molto che il proibito avere i cani
perché è proibita per i cani un animale
domestico domestico perché il il cane
immessi in perù è
il mezzo di difesa del sistema di
sicurezza più economico in circolazione
e il fatto che qualcuno avesse un cane
che quindi volesse proteggere la sua
casa mostrava la non confidenza che
aveva negli altri quindi se qualcuno
della comunità vuole avere un cane deve
chiedere a tutti gli altri
l'autorizzazione per avere un cane solo
per per compagnia e per assicurare che
appunto non ha problemi di sicurezza
un'altra cosa che mi ha impressionato
sempre sulla stessa isola e la loro
apertura all'innovazione
perché non hanno un rifiuto
dell'evoluzione ma hanno una specie di
intelligenza collettiva perché le
decisioni vengono prese da tutta la
comunità per per esempio in questo caso
hanno deciso di investire tutti i
proventi del turismo
i pannelli solari per avere un minimo di
energia elettrica sufficiente per una
lampadina per per casa praticamente e
per poter pompare l'acqua dal lago fino
alla torre d'acqua l'altra cosa
particolare che queste persone rifiutano
l'uso della forza animale e quindi la
torre d'acqua è stata portata da tutta
l'intera comunità a piedi dal lago fino
in cima alla collina se vedete le foto è
veramente impressionante ed è ovviamente
una cosa che può essere fatta solo se
tutta la comunità partecipa facendo
questo tipo di ragionamento mi sono reso
conto un po di quello che volente o
nolente faccio quotidianamente ed e ho
simulato un po a quello che è quello che
succede con le api quello che fanno le
api con i fiori che cosa fanno le api
con i fiori fondamentalmente volano da
un fiore un altro e impallinano
impollinano i fiori quello che è
interessante che il loro primo scopo non
è in collinari fiori la però ha solo a
cercare il nettare per fare il miele per
il suo scopo principale non è
impollinare il suo scopo principale
il suo obiettivo è ben altro
involontariamente avviene questo il
parallelo è un po più o meno quello che
che mi sento di fare il mio scopo
principale non è diffondere delle idee e
portarle a destra a sinistra e quella
che involontariamente con la mia
curiosità di io personalmente vado
viaggio e cerco di scoprire delle cose
nuove e involontariamente porto queste
informazioni queste nozioni a destra
sinistra nelle varie culture quello che
appunto sottolineare che lo scambio
avviene completamente in maniera
involontaria
io non so quello che vi potrà colpire
delle foto dell'immagine delle storie
che vi ho raccontato magari niente
magari tutto magari vi permette di
aprire un'attività o dico a cambiare
modo di pensare ma non è nel mio scopo
nel sotto il mio controllo
non sono io a controllare quello che
prendo e non sono io a controllare
quello che poi recepite questo funziona
secondo me solo a due condizioni la
prima condizione o che ovviamente che la
persona che si muove si sposta viaggia
lo faccia con curiosità per poter
prendere le cose se sia giusta curiosità
quello che trovate quello che potrebbe
portare a caso sono dei self icon con i
monumenti se invece guardate i dettagli
guardate fare domande e cercare di
capire che cosa sta succedendo intorno
riuscire a avere informazioni a catore
informazioni d'altra parte che
altrettanto importante è la condivisione
perché se io facessi viaggi del tutto
personali per carità trovo altro me
stesso presto eccetera ma non alti
nessun modo di condividere queste
informazioni è un sapere che resta del
tutto personale
nel momento in cui queste informazioni
le condivido indistintamente
chiunque può assumerle e farle proprie e
questo è il mio modo di cucinare
ovviamente